Yesterday, Donald Trump told what might be
the biggest whopper about the virus so far,
and he's told many whoppers during his press
conference yesterday and the day before.
Donald Trump has again played the role of
someone who is pretending to have been on
top of the virus since day one, despite the
fact that he's ignored it and downplayed it
and lied about it.
Since the beginning.
Here's what Donald Trump said two days ago.
I just say this.
We have an invisible enemy.
We have a problem that a month ago nobody
ever thought about.
Nobody.
You know, I read about it.
I read about many years ago, 1917, 1918, I've
seen all of the different the different problems
similar to this that we've had.
This is a bad one.
This is a very bad one.
This is bad in the sense that it's so contagious.
It's just so contagious.
And then again, yesterday, Donald Trump said,
well, I don't I don't no one determine recession.
But I just say this.
We have an invisible enemy.
We have a problem.
That a month ago nobody ever thought about
nobody in the you know, I read about it.
I read about many years ago, 1917, 1918.
I've seen all of the different the different
problems similar to this that we've had.
Now, first of all, Trump himself was briefed
about Corona virus two months ago.
So even people in his administration were
thinking about it two months ago and brought
it to Donald Trump.
Then you merely need to look at the list of
lies that Donald Trump told about this to
understand the sort of weaponized ignorance
that we are dealing with here.
We're putting a long list on the screen, a
few highlights.
On February 24, Trump said the situation is
under control.
On February 26, he said corona virus is a
flu.
Also on that same day, saying cases in the
U.S. are down to close to zero.
Obviously, it couldn't have been more wrong
as we now have, you know, almost 10000 diagnosed
and probably half a million in total.
Feb. 28, Trump suggested an immigration link
to the virus.
On March 2nd.
Some sort of vaccine is coming soon.
It's not on March 4, Trump tried blaming it
on Obama, saying Obama impeded testing and
that is not true.
And then countless times, Trump and others
claiming that there is no test shortage, that
we have tests that anybody can get tested
and on and on and on.
You all know it.
Consider that two months ago, Joe Biden wrote
an op ed criticizing Trump's response to coronavirus.
That was two months ago.
Consider that we at the David Packman show
weren't particularly early on this, and we
covered it only when it reached the US on
the broadcast show.
We talked about it earlier on the bonus show.
That was January 30th.
That's almost two months ago at this point.
So when Trump says nobody knew, nobody heard
of, nobody imagined, all he means is he didn't
know about.
He didn't take it seriously.
He didn't care.
He said it with Category 5 hurricanes.
I don't know if you remember, but at some
point in the last year, I think it was Trump
said when we were facing a Category 5 hurricane
who's even heard of a Category 5 hurricane.
There had been multiple Category 5 hurricanes
under his presidency when he said that.
So he had like a minute during which he seemed
more sober and serious.
Three days ago or two days ago, during a press
conference, he is back to calling it the Chinese
virus.
He's back to blaming anybody that he can.
He's back to bragging and rating his performance
as a 10 out of 10.
That's what we're dealing with today.
We're going to have to solve this.
Despite Trump.
But that being said, it's still good that
he's saying it's serious because a lot of
these ignorant people, particularly with ignorant
red state Republican governors who continue
to go to the beach and go to concerts and
pretend like everything's fine, they will
prevent us from dealing with this as quickly
as we can.
Make sure you're following the David Packman
show on Instagram at David Packman Show.
We'll have polls and data and questions about
this there.
And
while you're
on the ground, follow me.